i've been testing out sony's new xm4
truly wireless earbuds and i've gotta
admit
that these things have blown me away in
a few different areas
compared to apple's airpod pros that
i've heard many times
and what's pretty clear to me at this
point is that we're getting really
really close
to peak earbuds or at least what earbuds
were always meant to be
and even though the xm4s aren't perfect
and i'll explain
why and how in this review they've
definitely gone a long way
so before i get into my favorite
features about these earbuds and why i
actually think they're worth
the hefty 279 dollar price tag i want to
go back to the roots of these sony
earbuds
and truly wireless earbuds in general to
show you guys just how far we've come
and how we got here as we all know
wireless earbuds like this have been the
standard for so long already
that many of us especially the younger
generation have forgotten how things
used to be
almost a decade ago every single pair of
earbuds were
wired and for many years the majority of
people
would be buying cheap earbuds like the
jvc gummies
which were considered budget at around
seven dollars a pair
or they just be using whatever came in
the box with their smartphones
like the newly updated apple earpods
that came with the iphone 5.
and then in 2013 we finally started
seeing wireless earbuds like the
motorola buds
which came with a neckband housing the
battery and bluetooth chip
with wires going up to the earbuds and
then that quickly evolved
into wireless earbuds like the jaybird
blue buds
x which were much more compact ditching
the bulky headband but of course still
requiring the cable connecting both
sides
because it was the most reliable way to
make sure the audio between both ears
played perfectly in sync and then of
course in 2016
apple revealed the original airpods with
their new w1 chip
that perfectly sync the audio and push
the entire industry forward
with new features like auto pods when
you take an airpod out of your ear
and the ability to just use one airpod
at a time
while the other one is charging in the
case which was also revolutionary at the
time
but now shifting over to sony's part of
the story the same month that apple
released their airpods
sony launched their mdr xb50bs
wireless earbuds for 80 dollars which
still came with a cable
that rested on the back of your neck it
wasn't until the following year
that sony came out with their wf-1000x
earbuds
being the very first pair of fully
wireless earbuds
with active noise cancellation something
that the airpods didn't have at the time
and of course they came with a pretty
massive charging case
and on top of that the noise
cancellation apparently still
sucked barely making a difference
compared to passive noise isolation
but a year later sony released their
best in class
wf 1000xm3s the earbuds that held the
crown for
having the best noise cancellation even
better than the airpods pro
which were released later that year but
those new xm3s definitely weren't
perfect
the charging case was still absolutely
massive
compared to the airpods pro and they
didn't even support wireless charging
the buds themselves were quite a bit
more bulky and they offered
zero sweat or water resistance compared
to ipx4
on the earpods pro and now in 2021 we
finally have sony's
brand new xm4s and like i said in the
beginning of this video
these earbuds have basically reached
their peak
by fixing so many of the previous issues
all
in one update so let's get right into
everything that's changed
first up the charging case has been
totally redesigned
now less than half the size of the
previous one
allowing you to finally be able to fit
it into that little mini pocket
that comes on most pairs of jeans and
because of the new flat bottom
it can now sit upright and finally
support wireless charging
the finish also got an update as well
with a new
matte texture that's much more scratch
resistant compared to the xm3s
the inside of the case now looks much
more clean and modern
no longer featuring blatantly visible
rectangular magnets
with them now being tucked underneath
the plastic casing
and i also noticed that the magnets are
now more powerful
giving you a satisfying snap when you
place them in
as well as keeping them perfectly secure
so they don't fall out if you drop the
case
as far as the earbuds themselves they've
also been completely redesigned
with a more round boba shape a new matte
finish
and some new design details that really
make them look and feel more premium
than before
and i really like how the new foam ear
tips perfectly match the color and
texture of the earbuds
the flashing led light on the xm3s is
now gone
which i actually prefer because it made
them look a bit cheesy
and i really like how the new xm4s now
sit
perfectly within your outer ear instead
of sticking out like the old ones do
and i'm glad they removed the sony logo
from the face
giving them a more clean look however i
did find that this new fit isn't as
comfortable as the old ones
because it can sort of press against
your ear and on top of that the new
phone tips are a little bit annoying
because you have to squish them each and
every time you put them into your ears
and then wait for the phone to expand
before removing your finger
and because of all of that these sonys
are nowhere near as comfortable as the
airpods pro
especially since they're heavier and
they don't feature a venting system
to relieve pressure from the inside of
your ears like the airpods pro have
so even though these new xm4s feature an
incredible
eight hours of listening time with
active noise cancellation enabled
compared to six hours in the old xm3s
and only four and a half hours on the
airpods pro
you absolutely cannot listen for eight
hours straight
because your ears will start hurting
after just a couple
but thanks to the foam ear tips you get
an incredibly good seal
which helps the xm4s achieve the best
noise cancellation that i've ever heard
on any earbuds destroying the airpods
pro
and removing so much noise that i can
hear subtle creaks and pops
inside of my own head as i look around
instead of the blaring ac
vent noise in our office which i can't
hear at all with these in
these things are literally rivaling the
noise cancellation performance of the
airpods max
which cancel almost every bit of noise
on an airplane flight
and they also have an ambient mode for
the times when you need to hear
something or talk to someone
which you can enable by tapping the left
earbud or you can use the speak to chat
feature
within the sony headphones app which
automatically switches to ambient mode
when you speak
and it works surprisingly well however
the ambient mode itself isn't the best
since it introduces a bit of extra white
noise so it's nowhere near as good as
the airpods pro's transparency mode
which basically makes it seem like you
don't have anything in your ears at all
but the sony's definitely get the job
done the touch controls work much more
reliably than before
and they're fully customizable for each
ear within the app
which also comes with an equalizer with
easy to use controls
for different frequency bands and as far
as the sound quality
i am completely blown away with these
even coming from the earpods pro
the high notes even in the bright preset
which i recommend
are incredibly clean and not too sharp
where they hurt your ears
which is something that i've experienced
with the airpods pro
which unfortunately don't support eq
customization
the mids and vocals on the sony's are
just so
clean and full with not even a hint of
distortion anywhere
with very impressive separation of
frequencies allowing you to hear the
subtle notes from various instruments
without having it all clashed together
like on some other earbuds
and as far as the base it's really
enjoyable being very deep punchy and
tight
all at the same time being kept together
nicely
even while high notes are simultaneously
playing and i honestly can't say the
same thing for the airpods pro
that do have great bass reproduction but
lack
a bit of that extra base volume that the
sony's give you
i'm honestly just extremely impressed
especially since the last up to eight
hours with noise cancellation enabled so
as far as comparing the sony xm4s to the
airpods pro
they outclassed them in terms of the
overall sound quality
the noise cancellation and the battery
life
which are three of the most important
features for fully wireless earbuds
and on top of that the other less
important features now
match up much better compared to the
airpods pro like getting a smaller case
with wireless charging
and finally getting ipx4 water
resistance
the only downsides include the sony's
being
way less comfortable and not supporting
multi-connect
which is a bit weird considering the
last main downside
which is the higher 279 dollar price tag
compared to 250 dollars for the airpods
pro
but given the fact that the pros are on
sale right now
for only a hundred ninety dollars on
amazon it does make the choice quite a
bit more difficult
but i think i've figured it out if
you're an android user
seriously just pay the extra cash for
the sony's because you won't be getting
anything from the apple ecosystem
with the airpods pro and the sony's also
absolutely destroy the competition
including samsung's galaxy butts pro
which i showed you guys in our recent
best buds in 2021
video but if you're an iphone user
you've got to choose what you'd like
more
comfort price and convenience with the
apple ecosystem with the airpods pro
or better sound quality better battery
life
and the absolute best noise cancellation
and to be completely honest after
hearing how good these sonys are
i would probably go with these over the
earpods pro
even though i have an apple bias and
that says a lot about the new
sony xm4s so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this review
and if you did you'll find links to the
best deals on these sonys and the
airpods pro
down in the description below and
definitely click that circle about to
subscribe
and check out one of those two videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you
in the next video